business about the impact of the coroner
virus outbreak on Monday so the doubt
wipe out year-to-date gains yeah
Bitcoin is up around 30 percent so far
this year far more over the last 12
months so is it a safe haven in stormy
markets or something else entirely
Morgan Creek digital assets co-founder
and partner and Philippe Avila note
joins us now great to have you with us
so thanks for having me here make two
observations about their corner virus
outbreak not that we want to take away
from the tragedy that it represents but
the first thing was mining because a lot
of that happens in China yep thoughts
their big thing is a lot of
manufacturing plants are being shut down
and so those companies are losing
revenue but when it comes to mining
computers are doing most of the work it
takes very few humans so mining is not
impacted and it's also very
decentralized across the globe and so if
you get kind of a virus outbreak in one
geographic area
it doesn't necessarily affect the mining
hash rate nearly as much and so I don't
think that mining is really susceptible
to the same things that like a
traditional manufacturing company is
okay we're going to come back to that I
promise you but we'll move on to the the
point that I was just making now and I
think the perhaps lack of understanding
about how you view crypto specifically
Bitcoin relative to markets a safe haven
or a hedge doesn't necessarily have to
be rising when markets go down yeah a
lot of people confuse safe haven and non
correlation right and so a
non-correlated assets just means that
the value drivers are different right
you see stocks or other assets and the
traditional markets are driven by GDP
interest rates etc bitcoins not driven
by that bitcoin is a artificially capped
supply asset misterben by demand and
demand continues to increase and so over
time you expect supply and demand
economics to play out so sometimes you
could have Bitcoin rising when markets
rise sometimes it could go down that's
positive correlation it can also be
negative but what you're saying is
remember what the drivers are here and
they're different thing absolutely
Bitcoin over a long period of time has
been a non correlated asset and what I
think is exciting about that is when we
see times of global instability
geopolitical uncertainty
things like coronavirus etc stocks bonds
gold etc kind of do what you expect them
to do Bitcoin doesn't do that and so the
fact that it doesn't go up is not bad
it's actually it's a non-correlated
assets so it's doing exactly what it's
supposed to do for your portfolio which
is exactly why we think investors should
have it in there
critics would say though that hang on a
second you're telling me to add it to my
portfolio surely I want it to be doing
so the opposite thing when when markets
are going down yep
again as long as it is preserving your
wealth or increasing it that non
correlation makes it a safe-haven asset
right you don't want to have everything
in your portfolio have the same value
drivers that non correlation actually
reduces the overall risk of the
portfolio Bitcoin has served that
purpose for many many years now we think
that it will continue to do that into
the future so Brad darling how's the CF
Ripper was recently on and he said
what's going to define crypto assets in
2020 is the utility value we're on that
curve between a store of wealth
something that you just hold and the
price goes up versus actually something
that you can use its Bitcoin because a
lot of the criticisms that I read one
it's energy intensive it uses a lot of
energy and two in terms of transaction
speeds it's really slow yes so first
when it comes to the energy consumption
Bitcoin is using majority renewable
energy right people are having input
into that business a cost that is the
energy cost and so what they're actually
doing is they're going to find the
lowest cost energy which happens to be
renewable so we see things like gas
flaring waste-to-energy geothermal
hydroelectric etc so I think that's
actually driving a lot of innovation a
lot of criticism of that if you go to
China I mean that's cold fuel they are
fossil fuel fueled energy yes there's
definitely some not renewable energy but
there's many studies that have now come
public where 60 70 80 percent of the
energy consumption is actually renewable
energy in total in total yeah absolutely
and then when it comes to utility I'm a
transactions ID last year the adjusted
transaction volume on change so this is
not exchange traded volume rates like
that actually people sending it for one
purpose or another was all it was over
half a trillion dollars and so what that
means this is bigger than venmo
Apple pay PayPal etc in terms of
transaction volumes and so people not
doing it too often I guess the point
well so again people can complain about
transaction speeds cost etc but the end
of the day people are using this more
or than they're using venmo Apple pay
and PayPal as a store of wealth though
it's the biggest argument here for
Bitcoin the store Wow
it definitely serves a purpose as a
store of wealth we've seen that do very
well it's up 30% this year it's up 150%
over the last 12 months well people are
also using it to transact and send it
for one purpose or another to either
businesses or to other individuals
Warren Buffett very dismissive yesterday
he said shorting suitcases ie you know
people laundering money perhaps they're
not going to use suitcases anymore
they're going to use things like digital
assets Bitcoin specifically so my two
things with Warren first of all somebody
should tell them that Wells Fargo one of
the companies in his portfolio recently
was found guilty of helping the Sonoma
cartel launder a lot of money so I don't
know that I don't yes
so proof on anything else but obviously
things like that with Wells Fargo have
been a concern and the second thing is I
don't really take technology advice from
somebody who uses a flip phone or
doesn't use email right again you
shouldn't ask me for value investing
advice and so he kind of has his domain
which he's the best doesn't get it so
stay out of it basically people will
listen to his opinion because he's one
of the best investors of all time when
it comes to technology though I think
there's better people to listen to
things because seriously okay talk to me
about Sweden but if they've launched a
digital coil it's they're testing the
testing phases they are way more
advanced it seems than then even the
Chinese who are clearly pumping a lot of
money in investment yes so these central
back digital currencies are all coming
and really what I think people need to
understand is all of the central back
digital currencies are simply taking the
existing monetary policy and changing
the technology form factor right what
bitcoin does is it actually is a
different monetary policy it's not a
Fiat inflationary type model and so also
that we're gonna have is a competition
of currencies but it's not gonna be a
competition on technology won't be are
they digital are they not everything
will be digital instead what we're gonna
have is a competition of monetary policy
that's I think where we believe that the
Bitcoin monetary policy is superior to
central bank monetary policies and
ultimately Bitcoin will be the winner
and will be the next club order of
currency at some point in the future
we're gonna continue this conversation
there's always more to discuss your
100,000 core by 2021 and we're going to
come back to that energy the renewables
I'm going to do some digging see
popularly there thank you so much for
joining us stay strapped in the show or